- I think hello, by the way.
- Hi.
- You look so like bright like a light.
- Oh
- We just gonna start with that.
- Oh, thank you.
- And you walked in and I was just like
well, you make me happy just walking in.
- Great.
- That's a nice little
trick you have. (chuckles)
And I think the last time you were here
was around Mama's Hour.
So how are your kiddos doing?
- They are great.
My son is four.
- Yeah, mine's five.
- And he really loves
to run all of his cars
and even if it's not a
car, he turns it into a car
and into all of the walls.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- In all of the house.
And it's his favorite thing to do.
- It's a boy thing I think.
Cause my five year old
boy does the same thing.
- Really?
- He just loves destroying stuff.
- It's just about crashing things
and mushing it up,
- And wrestling.
- And throwing it and launching
himself off high places.
(audience awws )
- Yep. He thinks he can
jump on anything and often.
- And then when he lands he's like, oh!
And then he gets up
(audience awws)
and does it again.
- Yeah.
- It's such a different thing than girls.
- It's so different cause
my daughter is more cautious
and she's like,
- Yes!
- I don't know if that kind
of hurt the last minute.
He's like, maybe if I do it again,
I'll get used to it or something.
- Right?
- Like it's just
- Yeah.
- I think that's like the
difference between men and women.
- It's Venus and Mars all the way.
- Right?
- Yeah. So wait, how are you handling
because your daughters are
becoming teenagers, right?
- Well, one of them is full on teenager
and she is so tall and just
like a whole situation.
(sighs)
The one on the right that's Honor,
and then Haven is my middle child
and she is like the glue
that keeps everyone together.
(chuckles)
- And she is 10.
- Yeah.
- So she is doing the sort of
like you know preteen thing.
- Yes.
- And it's interesting because you know
they're caught between
being kids and adults.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And so they have all of these
very like grown thoughts and ideas,
- Large feelings.
- But without and so many feelings,
but without
(chuckles)
the like knowledge of life.
- Yeah the experience.
- And so yeah, the experiences
that you get in being you know mature.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Like us.
- Yes.
(audience chuckling)
- You know just something happens with age
and so they're like
they wanna do everything
and they wanna have like
complete autonomy to do and say
and feel and I'm like yes
but, I'm still your parent.
- Yeah.
- I'm gonna give you boundaries,
and you're gonna have rules and that's
- And the boundaries are
because you love them.
- I love them.
- Yeah.
- And I care about them and so,
I figured out a way of two things.
One is, I wanted to have a
good relationship with them.
So, I started going to therapy
with them when I felt like
- Like with them?
Not like
- With them like we went to therapy
and I was like I wanna
go to therapy with you
so you can tell me how you
want me to communicate with you
and how like obviously you're
gonna have to get punished
when you're not doing the right thing.
- Yeah.
- How do you want that to go down?
- Wait, does this work?
- It works.
- Okay.
- It actually works
because they then get to sort
of like speak their peace,
- Yeah.
- Speak their truth,
they feel seen and heard,
and the same punishment
doesn't really work with both of them.
- No.
- At all.
- Not mine either.
- Except the one punishment
that does work for both,
is I make them listen to a meditation
when they're being rotten.
(audience chuckles)
- Wait, are you good at meditation?
- No, but I make them
listen to a meditation.
(all chuckles)
- Okay. I'm like, I try so hard.
- Not because I can't sit in silence,
I need someone to talk
me through the things.
But yeah, I can listen to it.
- Yeah yeah.
- Absolutely.
- But it always like you listen to like
cause they have like gaps, right?
- [Guest] Yeah.
- So you like, listen and it's like
oh, if you're thinking of something
and it's always a very soothing voice
- Yeah.
- And it just let it fly away.
And I'm like, there's a lot
of flying happening in here.
Like it's like they never stops.
- No, but like the binaural beats
is sort of like,
- Yeah.
I like that.
- You know so, you get the binaural beats
behind someone talking to you,
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- That sort of the type.
And it's cool because it's sort of like
I used to get you know in trouble
and I was like probably
never not grounded.
(gasps)
- And grounding doesn't
really work for me.
- You don't seem like you
were like, you seem so good.
- I was sassy.
- Okay, okay.
(audience chuckles)
- Kind of mouth on me.
- Okay, okay.
- So, and it you know it's just like
when you're a curious kid and your
- Is this karma happening though?
Are your kid sassy with you?
- No, I have like said I'm
sorry to my mom a lot recently.
(both chuckle)
- Oh really?
- Yeah. I was like slipping and
I really put you through it.
- Oh man!
- I'm still doing a lot
of my healing with her.
- Yeah.
- With that.
- Well, you were young though.
- I was.
- To start out in this
industry, that's a lot.
But I was 19 and it's like
I can't even imagine at 12.
- Yeah.
- Like that's a lot.
- Like growing up in the public eye.
- Yeah, I was just like
a sassy kid and so.
- I know.
But also that's a lot of
pressure and a lot of things
put on you at such a young age.
So, I mean not giving you a pass,
I'm just saying like yeah,
it's good that you're saying sorry.
That's nice.
- It's good that I'm going
to therapy. (all chuckling)
- I'm in therapy too.
I think that literally, I
think from where I'm from,
people don't look down
upon it necessarily.
They're just like, I don't need it.
And I'm like I feel like
- Same with where I'm from.
- Especially when you
say you don't need it,
you probably are the
person that needs it most.
- The most.
(audience applause)
- And it's not it's really nothing,
I feel like except for just someone
outside of your everyday circle,
you're running your whole thoughts by
and they give you tools to kind of handle.
- Just tools to be able to.
- Especially relationships that maybe
- Yes
- You're not used to and you're like,
I'm under a real hard time.
- Also just when you're like
I wanna wake up every day
and if something comes up,
I wanna like still be able to be happy
and feel like
- And not let it rule your day.
- And not let it yeah. Totally
- Yep!
- Overcome my day.
- If like someone is
being some kind of way
or someone's coming at me
or it's like how can you just sort of like
approach things with love.
- Yeah.
- And try to be more in like
your happy space
- Yeah.
- And in a better vibration.
So that's all it is.
- And it's like anything
you're trying to do
to make yourself like
the best version of you,
I think is not.
- Yeah.
- If it's not harmful, that's awesome.
- It's great.
- It's a good thing, yeah.
(audience applause)
- So, we were talking about your kids.
So what do they think of
your TikTok dance moves?
- So here's the thing.
It's like I'm like basically
they think I'm the worst.
(both cackles)
and I'm just like can I just
remind you that I'm honey.
I'm Honey!
- Yeah.
(audience applause)
Exactly.
Did you see the movie ladies?
- And they're just like
mom, but when you do it,
- Look at that booty!
Look at that hip!
Look at the little one!
- They're like mom but when you do it,
it just feels like you're trying too hard.
- Look at that!
Look at her.
(audience applause)
No it doesn't.
They're jealous.
Jealous of your moves.
- I was like just let me live.
Just let me live.
It's fine.
- And have a good time.
I think it's so important
cause my daughter,
she thinks she's like you are so silly.
Like even the movie ended last night
and the ending credit's song comes on,
and we have a thing in our house
in the ending song comes on
no matter if it's sad or happy,
we have a dance party
and we don't know why.
We just get up and do it.
- That's great.
- And last night they were kind of tired
and I just was like
flailing around the room.
And I think it's like awesome
for your kids to see your character.
Cause then, I feel like
especially this teen age,
like kids I don't know if they're online
but it's like they get so trapped into
that mentality of like it's not cool
or like I can't be myself
or people won't accept
me or I won't get likes.
It's like a hard thing.
I think it's good you're
doing stuff like that.
- I think so and I also think
it's good for them to
like allow me to be silly.
Like allow me to be, to giggle
and allow me to like be a person.
And then I feel like
they'll have more compassion
you know in life for everyone else,
but also you know for me.
- For you'lls relationship.
- And for our relationship,
which I think is good.
- I have to say they had to
think this was pretty cool
because you got Zac Efron
chuckles
into one of your TikTok videos.
So I wanna show this video real quick.
- Okay.
(chuckles)
- This is amazing.
So they had to have
thought this was amazing
that you got him in.
Did they think you were cool?
- They were like wait, what?
Like is he coming over?
(audience chuckle)
Like how did you get him to do this?
Like does he think you're a stalker?
Like they were
(chuckles)
so confused about how it happened.
And I was like, I did a
job with him in Dubai.
And by the way, he did a video with me.
- Yeah, exactly.
(audience applause in awws)
- Like what are we even talking about?
- It's so funny because
my kids will be like
you know this person?
Like yeah, but they know me too.
I'm like wait, what?
(chuckles)
- Our kids don't care.
- They have no idea.
- So, I wanna ask you about your business
cause it's so phenomenal
what you've done with The Honest Company.
Its crazy.
- Thank you.
It's celebrating 10 years.
(audience applause)
It's incredible.
And tell everybody exactly
what the company does.
- Yes.
So basically, I created this company
that I just wish existed
and we make home products,
we make bath and body products,
we make children's products,
and we also make beauty products.
- Yeah. You know I was in the makeup chair
you know since I was 12 years old,
and so being able to have
like makeup that won't
you know give me out allergic reactions,
I have super sensitive skin,
- [Kelly] Me to.
- But also that don't have
any nasty chemicals in it.
- Yeah.
- So a lot of makeup that people
don't even realize a
lot of beauty products
have like pretty brutal chemicals,
- Yeah.
- And that's why we get you
know such bad reactions,
a lot of people have autoimmune,
- I do too.
I have all of that.
I have such a problem with makeup too.
Glow is backstage going.
(gasps)
She's not makeup artist.
- Yeah.
And so, I basically
wanted to create this line
that actually worked like
at the professional level.
But if you just want a five minute face
you're on the go, we
have products you know
skincare and makeup products.
- Yeah.
It's good for you.
It's like an over time.
It's like if you can have
makeup with skincare benefits,
and if you can have skincare
that really like is transformative
and does what it says it's gonna do,
- Yeah.
- And it's made with clean ingredients.
- That's The Honest Company.
(audience applause)
- That's really good. I love
it's such a brilliant idea
- Thank you.
- And I'm so happy it's done so well.
- Yeah.
- It's helped out so many
people especially moms like me
like starting out and you are
afraid of what to put with it.
It's so funny we put the
craziest stuff in our bodies
but then when it comes to your baby,
you're like wait, I gotta put
everything perfect for them.
- Yeah.
It was awesome.
- But you should think
about yourself as well.
- I do I do.
- You know thinking about your health
- Yeah.
(chuckles)
- You know what I mean?
- (chuckles)
- Like that's so important
- Yeah.
- cause that's also like quality
of life with your family.
- It is hard to find cause a lot of us
and my sister and I both,
we have like extremely and my kids,
we have extremely sensitive skin.
like saying way bad.
- Same.
- Yeah.
My eyes are watering now
you can probably tell
they water every day.
You're welcome.
And every five days a week.
- I'll give you your
makeup artist a full kit.
- I know we need to like try your stuff.
- Yeah cause our mascara is amazing.
And our hydrogel
which is like a water
based hydration cream.
It's insane and it's so good.
- Yep.
- But we have a bunch of awesome products
so I'll hook you up.
- Yeah. I'm gonna hold you up to that.
(chuckles)
- Okay.
So wait, so you also have is
it called Self-Care Sunday?
- I do.
I do Self-Care Sunday.
- I love this. So what
is a Self-Care Sunday?
What do you do?
- So it's like definitely a bath.
- I love a bath.
- And it's definitely like
there's crystals involved.
- Yeah.
- I'll listen to a meditation.
(gasps)
- You just sent up one of those bath balls
It's like myrrh is it?
- Yeah.
- It smells so good.
I cannot wait to take a bath with that.
- It's so nice.
- Yeah.
- It's like this calming
and I put on a face mask.
- Yeah.
- And like sometimes
my kids would join in.
- Yeah.
- You know it's just
like a nice thing to do
where it doesn't feel like
oh, that's mom's thing and like
- Yeah.
- You know or else I'll
get you know resistance
but I'm like join me in
Self-Care Sunday guys.
(audience chuckles)
- Let's Self-Care Sunday.
- Let's like not scream at each other.
(all laughs)
(audience applause)
Be chill today.
- And meditate with our mask on.
(audience applause)
- Yeah.
- Love that.
So if you, I love that.
And if you weren't busy
enough, I love this.
So now you have a
children's book too right?
- Yes, so.
- And it's called A Bear To Share right?
- A Bear to Share, yes.
So in honor of our 10 year anniversary,
the nonprofit that I
work with is Baby to Baby
and Baby to Baby is this
awesome organization
we scaled it in really to a national
and even global organization
to really provide basic
essentials for families in need.
So when you buy something from Honest,
you are supporting our effort
to give back to Baby to Baby
and part of this book was the same thing.
We wanted to teach kids.
You know it's hard to teach
kids compassion and giving
especially if like they just
know what they know, right?
- Yeah.
- And so this book really,
- And especially with a lot of adults
walking around without none, without any.
- Without any compassion or empathy.
- You know without any
compassion or empathy,
you're like I swear it's there.
- So this book is really
like a way to kind of
tell that story and make
meaning for children
so they understand you know
the importance of giving back.
But then also like seeing others
who may not have everything
the way that you do
or may have different life circumstances.
- I love that. My kids are gonna love it.
(audience applause)
I love the cover art.
- Oh yeah it's cool.
- It's captivating.
It's cool.
- Yeah.
And we wanted to make sure
also that our main character
you know looks like girls
that aren't the stars
of very many books and so
- Well, I love that.
- She's Afro-Latina and she's beautiful.
- I love it.
- And she's just like cool and
- I just it reminds me
of those little balls.
I used to wear those all
the time in my braids
when I was a kid.
The little balls, did you ever do that?
- Yeah, that was so good.
- And then you twist around.
I used to love those.
Just had a little bit of
nostalgia there for a minute.
- Right.
Got you back.
- Well I know I was like
roller skating all of a sudden
I know I was living my
best life. (chuckles)
Well, everyone in our studio
audience will get to enjoy
the story for themselves
because Jessica is giving
everyone a copy of the book
(audience applause)
And don't forget to look for her products
from The Honest Company in
stores and online y'all.
We've got more with Jessica Alba
and we'll be joined by comedian,
Rose Matafeo when we come back.